and tim anderson steps in the box after
the sox scored
with tim in the first inning in both
games the doubleheader yesterday and
here
up the middle to second and [ __ ]
hernandez who's late
and tim anderson is once again on to
lead off the game for the third straight
game
he can really get it done big effort tim
just puts a ban on the ball then beats
it at first base and the hit parade for
him
continues
[Music]
he's off wrote a second from vasquez tad
wasn't there
tim got around it that was rafael
devers coming in to cover its second
base through the shift and tim steele's
second
he gets a good jump and he's looking
back for contact
[Music]
you hear timmy yeah i did he tries to
swipe tag but he clearly misses him and
then tim decides you know what
i'll just drift off the back but you
can't get here in time anyway
that type of thing is a window into tim
anderson because he just glided past
devers
as that's rocking it down the left field
line toward the monster into the corner
it goes that's a fair
baseball for luis robert and tim's gonna
score
it is an rbi double and again the sox
are on the board in the first it's one
nothing
the at-bats of luis robert are getting
better and better this is a slider that
stays
pretty much over the middle of the plate
luis goes out and he cranks it
exit velocity
109.5 ball drifts away
two base hit runs scored
kiki to lead things off 262 with a pair
of home runs
hit a home run yesterday 02
good swing on this one there's a shot
that's high off the wall did it get up
on top of that shelf
he takes the turn and back to first boy
that was awfully close to getting out
that might be a home run red sox think
so
yeah that's a home run i believe that
ball's gone now that's a home run
you can tell by the noise that it made
it didn't clank left a tin no question
over that red line over that little
shelf out there on top of the monster
rule this one gone and there it is so
[ __ ] can come the rest of the way and
this game
will be tied up in the first inning
hernandez with a home run verdugo with a
single martinez with a single
nobody out there on the corners
and that one is into right field down
for a base hit
here comes verdu going to score and the
throw will keep on rolling but martinez
will stop there at second another run in
2-1 boston
another change-up it's away it's not a
bad pitch moving away but he reaches
across the plate
and just hooks it in the right field for
the base hit
a lot of changeups have been hit here in
the early going
so marwin trying to put a hurt on
chicago right away and he scalds that
one into right field
martinez in the score red sox just keep
on hitting the first
six men have hits and it is 3-1
a lot of change-ups being hit for base
hits
that ball away too but hooked again by
gonzales
one run comes across
so red sox leading at three to one
nobody out
a little check swing roller here lamb
will fire on to first base as another
run comes in
tossed a no-hitter last season in august
against the pirates he struck out 13. he
certainly was
dominating in that one in every respect
not today
line drive base head softly hit that's
going to bring in another mishandled out
there
here comes the trail runner throw into
second will not get franchie
and two more runs score to make it six
to one
they really are they're taking exactly
what he's giving them they're not trying
to do too much
cordero going to the opposite field this
time little bobble in the outfield
and fortunately francie makes it in the
second base because the second run would
not have scored if he's out
but he makes it in there safely and that
second run scores
took his eye right off the baseball
looking up to see the runner
red sox opening the game with six
straight hits and so here comes jd
martinez for the second time in the ball
game
already he's one for one with a single
swang and a high fly ball jumped on this
baby that's deep to left
back back back and it is gone
jd with number six and the red sox lead
it
seven to one and look at the location of
this curveball right here
oh just stays right up about belt high
and i mean jd
he'll knock that out of the park uh
eight out of ten times
i thought they were just messing with me
saying just wave your arms like a madman
if the lights go out they don't do that
to the voice of the red sox
popped up in the center robert coming
over
he'll make the catch tagging up here
comes devers he's in to score it is
eight to one
and uh i miss that great
that's a fair ball down the third base
line off the sidewall
and adam eaton is gonna go for two
scoring madrigal it's an rbi double
and it's eight to two this is where the
shortstop usually comes into play we've
talked about it
the odd configuration of the third base
line in fenway park
[Applause]
two down bases clean and the old one
swinging a high fly ball that one's
driven to right
back it goes that baby's gone
red sox swinging for defenses today
that's their third home run and they
lead it
nine to two well no doubt about this
this fastball middle lid he gets the
barrel of the bat out
and he knows right away that's got
plenty to get it out of fenway park
over the bullpens about five six rows
and a line drive sliding stab
throw on and got him in first base
marwin gonzalez with a dandy to steal a
hit from jake lamb and the red sox lead
it by
seven
to first base and overrun there by abreu
here's the throw into third in a rundown
and the tag will be applied to marwin
gonzalez
christian vasquez able to score
to left field and this
is down oh boy cordero didn't really
know what to do with that baseball and
adam eaton has himself an rbi
tim scores it is 10 to 3. charge that
one to franchi
i mean he's got all kinds of room to
make this catch ivaldi thinks he's out
adam thinks wait a second he's not
playing that one too well
and he gets it back in
eating up the middle and that'll get a
run home the sox will make it 10-4
garcia scores tim to third
yeah mercedes will throw here we saw
willian's astonisho throw the other day
for minnesota so it's catcher pitcher
week
hard hit tim's got it short and that is
a double play
this is a bullet tim is right there and
then
oh frangie make the line drive go
through
and another hit for jd and he'll drive
in another run
[ __ ] scores red sox now lead at 11-4
second rbi of the day for jd martinez
0-2 hook to the shortstop
gonzalez gets rid of it and got him at
first base
and a red sox win here on patriots day